[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro dédié à vos idées sorties
tout de suite c'est le sommaire de ce
vendredi 6 juillet la littérature sous
toutes ses formes à l'honneur à saint
quentin en yvelines dans le cadre de
l'opération partir en libre menée par le
ministère de la culture le réseau des
médiathèques organise des animations
jusqu'au 21 juillet nous ferons le point
sur les ateliers avec armelle ou brié
vice-présidente de l'agglomération en
charge de la culture
comment vivent les abeilles et surtout
comment les protéger france miniature
invite petits et grands à répondre à ces
questions en compagnie d'apiculteurs des
animations proposées tous les mercredis
du mois de juillet un voyage sensoriel
et un bond dans l'histoire dans notre
rendez-vous junior mélanie poquet nous
parlera d'une exposition pour les plus
petits à gris en cours on ira également
à la rencontre du patrimoine pour les
plus grands 2 200 sites français
accueillent des jeunes lord chantier de
restauration
à noter dès à présent vos rendez-vous
pour la fête nationale à saint quentin
en yvelines dans les communes de
l'agglomération ça commence dès le 13
juillet pour profiter d'un feu
d'artifice ce sera au bassin de la
sourderie pour montigny voisins le
bretonneux
dès 21h30 première partie de soirée avec
un bal à elancourt et maurepas le feu
d'artifice sera tiré à 23 heures à la
coulée verte 23h aussi pour les clayes
sous bois et plaisir dans le parc du
château et attrapes dans le parc du
village à 23 heures également
et le 14 juillet les festivités se
poursuivent chez les pompiers cette fois
de l'esj les pompiers de montigny le
bretonneux la caserne organise son 2e
balle de sapeurs-pompiers au centre
d'incendié et de secours
tombola animations concerts et bien sûr
dancefloor vous voyez à l'écran des
images de l'édition de l'an dernier on
regarde un extrait de la vidéo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
la fin de l'année scolaire et les congés
d'été signe le retour de remets tes
tongs à magny les hameaux thème de cette
9e édition le golfe à la veille de la
ryder cup la compétition de golf est
organisé en septembre à guyancourt
au programme deux remettez tombe cette
année ateliers artistiques manuelles ou
sportifs
une semaine d'activités gratuites sur
l'esplanade gérard philipe
l'opération commence dès le 9 juillet à
14 heures
thérèse mallem merad vente à magny les
hameaux était sur le plateau de grégory
canale pour en parler dans le statut de
journal c'est un événement qui est très
attendu par les manies croire beaucoup
d'activités pour les jeunes c'est
souvent la semaine où il qu'ils
attendent avant de partir en vacances ou
pendant leurs vacances et c'est
tellement de choses qui est offerte par
la municipalité gratuitement dès lundi à
partir de 14 ans commencera l'événement
remettons donc pour eux ces voix là on
enchaîne tout de suite avec des
activités et beaucoup de joie pour eux
parce qu'ils ont énormément d'activités
qui leur sont proposés
du 9 au 21 juillet saint quentin en
yvelines participent à l'événement
partir en livre une manifestation
proposée par le ministère de la culture
pour découvrir la littérature sous
toutes ses formes
découverte de la programmation avec
notre invité des ateliers des balades
contées et des chasses aux trésors
l'opération partir en livres investis
les médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines où s'amusent avec carmelo brié
vice-présidente de l'agglomération en
charge de la culture bon jour en jour
alors c'est la deuxième édition de cette
manifestation et ça commence ce lundi 9
juillet se languit ne criait ça se
terminera pour sur le territoire de
saint quentin le 21 juillet avec une
grande manifestation à la commanderie
des templiers
c'est une manifestation qui est lancé au
niveau national
donc nous avons le label pur crochète
manifestations et chats nous profitera
au sens où on apparaîtra sur leur site
en tant que partenaire et donc dès lundi
on pourra retrouver des ateliers
notamment à lille le loisir il ya des
animations une une balade contée
c'est la ville de loisirs c'est là le
conseil régional etc du 9 juillet au 15
juillet il y aura un triporteur tous les
a promis qu d'accord alors qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un tri borter à tribord terre
c'est un vélo avec une grande une grande
caisse où il y aura en particulier des
livres dans tout bon pour asservir exact
alors on précise que cette opération est
en effet proposé un par le ministère de
la culture est organisée par le centre
national du livre c'était important que
saint quentin en yvelines se joignent à
cet événement alors c'est surtout très
important pour saint quentin
parce que c'est la période de début de
vacances c'est la période où il commence
à y avoir des loisirs plus de temps est
ce le moment de faire découvrir tout ce
que l'on peut trouver dans les
médiathèques dans les livres voire alors
dans les livres mais mais pas q parce
qu'il y aura aussi des ateliers aux
agences krabi c'est l'un des couvertures
lits puis dans au sens large du terme
et ça pourra se faire
c'est le livre les histoires tout ce
qu'on peut les romans ce qu'on peut
trouver à l'intérieur des livres et donc
ça sera fait sous le fait d' état de
forme
il y aura par exemple à plaisir il y
aura un goûter et aux puits avec des
lectures de contes
il y aura du scrapbooking c'est une
autre manière d'apporter le livre il y
aura des escarpins et de lecture
spectacle aussi des dessins est en fête
avec une participation aussi de
partenaires comme la librairie mille
feuilles de trappe comme l'autre le
librairie sel qui vient d'ouvrir à saint
quentin
non je ne me rappelle plus le nom telle
horreur on va quand même parler un petit
mot également sur la chasse au trésor
alors c'est le 13 juillet à guyancourt
en quoi ça consiste cette chasse au
trésor
alors la chercheuse trésor c'est de
trouver des trésors à partir d'énigmes
et ses effets sur le thème des contes de
ou des livres c'est une autre manière de
raconter une histoire découvre une
histoire toujours joui découvrir et
d'avoir envie après de connaître plus
sur les sur les ij pas tout ça c'est en
fait donné envie de lire
c'est ce que j'avais à dire je dois
l'objectif de cette manifestation c'est
vraiment de faire sortir le livre des
délais habituels de donner vie aux
histoires et alors c'est bien parce que
en même temps par exemple quand vous
parlez de la chasse aux trésors ça se
passera au jardin des cocottes et donc
en même temps c'est le livre la nature
il n'y a pas de comment je veux dire le
plaisir de livres c'est aussi d'être
dans le plaisir de lire c'est aussi
d'être dans un certain environnement et
effectivement quand on voit tout ce qui
se passe sur sur saint quentin
on va voir que c'est dans différents
lieux et
et justement on associe la lecture à la
manière de réfléchir et au bien-être et
au bien-être bonheur de vivre
c'est vrai que le livre tout de suite on
s'imagine c'est soit tout seul chez soi
c'est qu'il faut que ça peut être
porteuse a envahi les livres justement
quand on commence tout petit en fait
c'est quand même les comptes c'est les
histoires ça fait rêver c'est voilà
c'est paco lab il est une autre manière
d'aborder la vie réelle on vous l'avait
voté tout à l'heure mais cette
manifestation trouvera son temps
d'honneur le 21 juillet lors avec une
journée spéciale à la commanderie des
templiers avec une journée spéciale à la
commanderie des templiers ou lassé du
matin au soir et on retrouvera
effectivement les skates game donc il
sait résoudre des énigmes autour du
compte on va retrouver la chasse au
trésor le furet du nord ça c'est
l'hallali mort et et dont j'avais oublié
le nom
voilà qui sera présentée qui fera des
animations avec des dessins par exemple
il y aura la réalisation d'une fresque
géante sur le livre il y aura le musée
de la poésie puisque la lecture c'est
aussi la poésie et je ramais même pas
les costumes donc oui les costumes et
les comptes c'est bien le livre se
déguiser en personnages de quoi
exactement
alors attention de tout c'est toutes ces
animations sont disponibles sur le site
kiosque de saint quentin
parce que certaines animations comme les
skins game cette demande des
réservations mais tout est gratuit
on présente et gratuit je vous racontais
gratuit par contre je veux dire en
fonction du nombre de personnes qu'on
peut accueillir à un moment donné il
faut réserver très bien merci beaucoup
armés l'ouvrier d'avoir été avec nous
pour nous parler de partir en livre à
saint quentin en yvelines
alors on voulait compris à l'ensemble de
la programmation est à retrouver sur le
site internet kiosque de pointe qui
point fr et vous avez jusqu'au 21
juillet pour en profiter et image signée
patrick jacques de dixmude et toki nirhy
lanto merci à eux pour les moyens
techniques engagés depuis déjà deux ans
dans la protection des abeilles le parc
france miniature organise des rencontres
avec des apiculteurs
crédit du mois de juillet des quiz des
jeux et des animations pour comprendre
l'importance de ces petites bêtes
indispensable à notre alimentation est
la nature
l'image d'aurélie rond et de toxic nirhy
lanto en une année la reine d'une ruche
est capable de pondre près 2 400 milles
eu un nombre élevé mais nécessaire car
une abeille ouvrière ne vit que 30 à 45
jours à france miniature des animations
avec des apiculteurs sont proposés pour
en apprendre plus sur ces pollinisateurs
pourquoi les abeilles cette petite
histoire elle remonte à 2015 quand une
habitante d'el en cours nous a
sollicités en nous expliquant qu'elle
souhaitait se lancer dans l'apiculture
nous a sollicités pour les installer à
france miniature
on a accepté le projet parce qu'on avait
également nous envie de s'inscrire dans
un projet de protection de
l'environnement
mieux découvrir tout cet environnement
là le monde des abeilles des ruches de
l'apiculture et de le faire découvrir à
nos visiteurs
atelier collage réalisation de bougies
en cire d'abeille et chasse aux insectes
les enfants peu habitué à ce type
d'exercice ont surmonté leur peur pour
attraper une abeille et pour l'étudier
lors d'appels sont surtout valider son
bon gentil jaune la regarde assez
d'accord donc ça c'est la veille
au début on a quelque chose on a capturé
les abeilles pouvoir leur race et tout
d'un coup d'état mais on a découvert
comment elles naissent et comment
elles se développent et on a aussi eu
des abeilles de toutes les différences
une découverte de ces insectes
indispensable à notre alimentation
les apprentis apiculteurs sont attendus
tous les mercredis après midi du mois de
juillet en ce premier week-end de
vacances on voyage dans un autre monde
et dans l'histoire avec le rendez-vous
des juniors bonjour mélanie alors je
sais que vous allez trouver cette
semaine maintenant je vous propose qu'on
commence par les poupées ty en première
à guyancourt les enfants âgés de 6 mois
à 6 ans ont une mission celle de sauver
des bruits disparu une aventure à vivre
grâce aux voyages d'amélie l'armée lit
c'est une petite fille qui un matin
découvre que tous les bouts de la ville
ont été dévorés alors elle décide de
partir à la chasse et dans cette expo
tout est permis ou presque on peut
parler on peut toucher et surtout on
peut écouter est venu voir la créatrice
nous en dire quelques mots
c'est un moyen bien sûr de leur
permettre d'être à l'écouté de faire
attention un petit peu ce qui se passe
autour d'eux et ben là d'une manière
plus sensible de regarder d'écouter de
voir de toucher et de vivre
une expérience sensorielle c'est un
camaïeu de tissus de couleurs qu'on peut
trouver dans le ciel avec des textures
différentes
donc là on est sur le toucher un petit
peu plus loin on a aussi des galets sur
la plage donc là l'idée c'est
d'apprendre quelques notions de rythme
alors pour les aventuriers il faut pas
traîner avant qu amélie par te demander
de l'aide à d'autres enfants puisque
l'exposition est à découvrir à la maison
de quartier au but peut revoir jusqu'au
samedi 7 juillet et pour les plus grands
alors pour les plus grands la ont fait
un bond dans l'histoire ça vous dit qu
amy williams pas trop loin quand même
là on va partir sur une activité qui
s'appelle ça s'appelle non patrimoine
c'est un dispositif s'adresse aux jeunes
âgés de 6 à 18 ans alors pour 2010 et ce
sera qui avait plus de 210 sites
français qui a accueilli des jeunes dans
les yvelines plusieurs sites sont
concernés pour royal des champs à magny
les hameaux la maison elsa triolet luz
aragon qu'on voit l'image c'est à
saint-arnoult ennuis et la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet alors pour
cette dernière pour les vacances d'été
les enfants vont devenir des bénévoles
sur un chantier de restauration 12
d'entre eux vont découvrir les
techniques dans le temps pour réparer
les dégradations
c'est l'association rempart qui s'en
occupent écouter ni fait maçonnerie
taille de pierre ce dont on a besoin
pour restaurer le site sur lequel on est
mais savoir faire anciens notamment
parce que en maçonnerie traditionnelle
on va pas leur apprendre à monter du
parfum on va plutôt leur apprendre à
remettre des moellons dans un mur avec
du mortier à la chaux donc voilà c'est
vraiment les savoir faire anciens c'est
important aussi cette question de
transmission qui sachent qu'il ya
différents types de maçonnerie qu on ne
restaure pas pareil qu'on construit une
maison aujourd'hui alors remparts a
aussi eu des chantiers cet été pour les
adolescents un petit coup belle sur
leurs sept essais mon patrimoine c'est
aussi de l'archéologie de l'écriture de
la réalisation vidéo il ya tout un tas
de projets tous les rendez-vous sont
disponibles sur le site qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
alors pour le tournage vous avez déjà
testé l'expo sensorielle pour les tout
petits on vous retrouvera peut-être sur
un chantier de restauration cet été en
maçonnerie ni pourquoi pas aller dans
ton cas pour extra et mondo d'abord
travaillé ce alors merci beaucoup mais
l'ami vous en reparler de ce rendez vous
pour les plus jeunes vous êtes 8 loisirs
est maintenant terminé merci de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve vendredi
prochain pour le dernier numéro de la
saison ne manquez pas vos idées de
sorties pour les vacances scolaires les
vacances d'été
et d'ici là je vous souhaite un très
beau week end
m